- Hey.
(upbeat music)
And also.
And now.
- I was en engaged to
somebody in the industry
and sometimes what it does to people.
It mentally can scar you.
- [Interviewer] Has anything
changed since three years ago
for you, relationship wise?
(bright upbeat music)
Sex is sacred.
Three, two, one, go.
- I believe everybody has the opportunity
to choose what kind of sex they will have,
how they wanna have sex,
when they wanna have sex,
why they wanna have sex.
But then there's times I
just wanna be a dirty pig,
and just go out and do whatever I want,
and that's not sacred. (laughs)
I do think it can be,
and I also think it cannot be.
The connection I think is very important.
So it can be if you're
connected to that person,
that way it could be very sacred,
or else you can just have
sex without any emotions
and just ignore physical awesome space.
- People don't really get it.
When I'm on set, I'm Donny Sins.
When I'm at home, I'm normal me.
So when I have sex at home,
there's like a connection,
there's love, there's
all that other stuff.
- There's also not like a ring light
and a camera directly in your face.
- Exactly.
- Open up.
Let me see the penetration.
You're not being told that at home,
you're just going with the flow.
- Buck and I were actually
talking about this earlier,
but a lot of people they're
able to separate sex
and emotions and like feelings.
So it's not always sacred in
the way that people think.
For me in my brain, I
register it the same as like,
oh I went and worked out
at the gym with my friend,
but the workout just happened to be sex.
- [Interviewer] My family approves
of what I do for a living.
Three, two, one, go.
- They're not all for it.
They still want me to go back to college.
They found out the first day
that my first scene came out.
My mom, she called me and she was upset.
And then like a week after that
she was like I love you,
and you're still welcome to come home.
But they have my back.
All of my family members
they have went to college,
Ivy league schools,
and I'm the only one that
chose to become a sex worker.
It was always an awkward conversation
until I completely retired
from doing in person sex work,
that the tension is still there.
But they are happy that I'm not performing
or meeting up with anyone in person.
So they're comfortable
with me just being an online performer.
- They're happy that I'm
safe and I'm healthy.
And I have income coming in.
Before, the industry I
used to, I'm an addict.
I'm sober now, but like I used
to get in a lot of trouble.
I was living on the street.
It was a whole thing.
And then the industry helped
me create a safe space
for myself and also do a lot
of work on my mental health.
They would prefer if I did something else,
but they're not going
to hate for doing it.
- [Interviewer] It is hard
for me to find a relationship
because of my job.
Three, two, one, go.
Donny, let's start with you.
Has anything changed since three years ago
for you relationship wise?
- I was engaged to
somebody in the industry
and sometimes porn can
destroy relationships
and can destroy people.
'Cause I don't have her anymore.
And honestly, I don't know if I ever will.
Because sometimes what it does to people,
it mentally can scar you.
I'm still single.
Having sex with other people,
to most people is just not a normal thing.
Like I'm going to work
and I'm gonna go have sex with somebody.
As far as relationships,
I feel like the only thing
that has really changed
is I've accepted that.
Some people just, it
always starts off good,
and then after a while they
just feel a certain type of way.
So.
- [Interviewer] I'll read
off some popular search terms
and then you'll decide if it's problematic
or not problematic.
Ass to mouth. Three, two, one, go.
(bright upbeat music)
- Porn is fantasy people. Porn is fantasy.
Is it problematic to use ass to mouth?
Well, it depends on what
you mean by problematic.
Yeah, if someone does it
without having a clean,
before they do it, well, they're
gonna learn the hard way.
- So I think it's somewhat problematic,
because people wanna do that,
but you need to prepare correctly.
Because on movie sets they
are cleaning themselves out
completely.
- [Interviewer] How do
people clean themselves?
- With an enema. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] With an enema?
Milf. Three, two, one, go.
- Milf to me is an empowerment term.
We have a lot of ageism
within our industry
as well as a lot of other industries.
It's not problematic because
it's basically saying
that that lady who happens
to be a mom is super hot
and I'd like to her.
- I just feel bad sometimes.
'Cause you'll get the
girl you and you're like
oh you're the milf today?
And she'll be like, yeah, but I'm 25.
(all laughing)
- If she's like younger than you.
- So you put some makeup on her
that made her look older
and put a dress on her.
- [Interviewer] Teen. Three, two, one, go.
- This one is tricky because I
do fall in the teen category.
A lot of men are pervy
and they love the whole fresh
outta high school age play.
They love it and I'm gonna profit off it.
But it does get to the point
where it's a little bit it too far.
Like when you want me to
perform like I'm under 18.
I'm not gonna act like a
13 year old school girl.
That's just not gonna happen.
- When I was 18, 19, I
loved the teen category,
because I was like "Oh people, my age,
this is right up my alley.
This is perfect."
It can be somewhat problematic,
just because there are people like that.
But it's also not our responsibility
to regulate if somebody's
gonna be a creep.
- But when people see teen
or any of that within the porn space,
immediately people go to sex trafficking.
It's a little problematic
because we're getting shoved,
again into that space of sex trafficking,
and teenagers and youngsters,
which none of us wanna touch any of that.
- [Interviewer] COVID has affected my job.
Three, two, one, go.
- I'm happy COVID happened.
I'm sorry, (laughs) I have to say it.
COVID has put so much money in my pocket.
I have not seen since I've started out.
And I think it was because everyone
was just locked up in the house,
not knowing what was
going on in the world.
And the next thing that
they want was to be
in the comfort of their fantasy girl.
And I was that fantasy girl.
That's why everyone hopped
on the wave of OnlyFans.
I even jumped back into webcaming
and my numbers skyrocketed.
- It's weird, but people
would rather see your laundry
in the background,
than nice furniture and
paintings, you know?
- Yeah, that reality porn.
- 'Cause it's the realness of it.
I think people really want realness.
Polished porn, studio
porn, it's going away.
- When COVID hit, it affected me in like,
I wasn't going to set anymore.
We had a complete
shutdown in the industry,
where nobody was filming.
Some people started making a lot of money
but then like other people who
were doing only mainstream,
they were like, "What
are we gonna do now?"
Because they didn't have that.
So I feel like I was lucky
that I already had an
established online presence.
- [Interviewer] Sexual assault
is prevalent in the industry.
Three, two, one, go.
- It's a hot topic in our industry
because people want to be like,
"No, our industry is good."
We wanna protect each other.
And there's such a big stigma
against what we do as a job
that we're are almost afraid to speak up
when something happens.
How are we supposed to
make people accept porn,
if they know that people
in the industry getting
assaulted sometimes?
- I work in an industry
that's probably separate
from these people.
I work in more of the gay adult industry.
So in my 20 plus years
in the adult industry,
I would say I have not
seen a lot of that happen.
Of course it happens.
And it does happen more
in the straight industry
than it does in the gay
industry from my observation.
- We do have certain companies
that do have an entire
checklist that you have to sign
and go through with the girl.
And you guys talk about things,
but you have people who still break rules.
You have assholes in this
world. That's what they are.
- I guess I'm the only one strongly agree.
'Cause I have encountered sexual assault
numerous times on sets,
but sometimes I just hold it
in when those situations happen
until like a female performer,
she'll tell me like,
"Oh, like I'm shooting with this person."
I'll give her the heads up.
But as far as like coming out.
I literally have to wait for a big name
to speak up on a certain
performer to say something.
'Cause I know if I was to say something,
no one would really believe me
because I'm like the underdog,
no one really has my back like that.
I did a photo shoot.
It was in a beautiful mansion
with all these beautiful Instagram models,
photographers everywhere.
And I was getting ready to leave,
and this photographer
followed me to the bathroom.
I didn't even know he was
behind me, locked me in there,
and some things happened.
He's so well connected.
I knew I could not speak out
about it or say anything.
I had literally had to
walk out of this bathroom
with a smile on my face, put a mask on
and no one knew what I had to
endure for those 20 minutes.
- It's a power thing.
And they know they can do that to you.
By the way I wanna say I am
so sorry that happened to you.
It's just not okay.
- You scarred her like you...
There's things you can't take back
from set, from content, from anything.
- [Interviewer] People
should pay for porn.
Three, two, one, go.
- It's not a harmless
thing to be stealing porn,
because there's a huge
industry that's affected by it.
- We're not legit in a
lot of people's eyes.
So on some level they
feel like they can take
and steal our stuff,
because they just don't
have compassion for us.
And they don't look at us
as if we are actually running a business.
We have to pay for everything
you see in our porn.
How do we pay for that?
The only way we can get that money
is by you participating in
us creating that pornography.
- We make a lot of people happy
when they get that nut off.
So y'all should pay us. (laughs)
That's all I wanted to say.
- And like you guys asked
us earlier, this is art.
So you paid for every piece of art,
you paid for the clothing you have on,
you pay for glasses,
you pay for everything,
so why not pay for porn?
The work that it takes to do a video,
I think you guys would be very surprised.
Also, I feel like you guys
should pay for porn if,
I mean, especially 'cause
you want it regulated.
- We keep these things behind paywall.
- Yeah.
- And behind like age restrictions
to make it so the adult
movies are for adults.
- If you are a legit porn
person, like we all are here
we don't make it accessible to children.
Who's making it accessible to children?
Are the people who are
putting the free pornography
on the internet.
- [Interviewer] I would be
comfortable with my child
following in my footsteps.
Three, two, one, go.
- So I actually have a child
and not that he's asked me,
"Hey dad, can I get into porn?" (laughs)
But that being said, if he chose to do it,
I would say that I would try to steer him
a different direction,
because it's not an
easy industry to be in.
I do think there's better
choices for people to make.
But I would not discourage him 100%.
- I said, agree.
Not specifically for
filming mainstream porn.
I was thinking more so, the
route of contactless porn.
So like webcaming, phone sex operator,
even content creator,
somewhere where my child or future child
doesn't have to have
interaction with the consumer.
As far as like in person sex work,
that will be a problem,
because I know what could possibly happen.
And I don't even want my worst
enemy to experience that.
So I wouldn't want my child
to experience that neither.
- [Interviewer] It's a wrap.
(all cheering)
- We do a group hug?
- Good stuff.
- We did good.
Great representation of the industry.
- For real. We did amazing job.
- Thank you.
- Thanks guys.
(gentle upbeat music)